[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de los resultados ante la
primera vuelta en las elecciones
presidenciales en ecuador nos acompaña
desde quito santiago basabé politólogo y
docente asociado de ciencias políticas
de la facultad latinoamericana de
ciencias sociales de flacso en el
ecuador
gracias por estar con nosotros profesor
el nuevo presidente de ecuador será
elegido en una segunda vuelta el próximo
11 de abril qué significa para el país
el triunfo en primera vuelta del isr
dista correísta andrés araus hola buenos
días bueno las elecciones de ayer han
sido inéditas por varias razones una
lecturas dicho porque el señor correa
sigue teniendo una presencia
importantísima en el país han conseguido
un poco más del 30 por ciento a través
de su candidato araud y eso es realmente
una victoria yo creo que eso lo es con
los consolida como una fuerza importante
pero la segunda gran sorpresa es que
hasta lo que se conoce hoy falta todavía
un poquito de votos es que la segunda
vuelta sería con un candidato que
también viene de la izquierda entonces
sería algo inédito en toda la región al
menos que sean dos cándida
de la izquierda los que se disputan la
segunda vuelta con perspectivas
diferentes con enfoques distintos
evidentemente el señoría q pérez tiene
una visión distinta de lo que es el
manejo desde la izquierda pero son dos
tendencias similares y me parece que la
segunda vuelta va a estar rodeada de una
discusión no sólo en términos de cuáles
son las propuestas políticas y
económicas de uno y otro sino también de
dilucidar hacia quién girará unos
sueldos que fueron para el señor las
ahora profesor que está diciendo el
pueblo ecuatoriano con estos resultados
hacia dónde va la tendencia y qué podría
pasar el 11 de abril
mira yo creo que la tendencia del
ecuador y de américa latina es hacia que
el en el sentido de que la sociedad y la
de la población necesita más servicios
sociales yo creo que ahí hay un hartazgo
con la política por la falta de
seguridad social la falta de educación
la falta de salud ese estado de
bienestar partido que nunca tuvo américa
latina pero que ahora se ha incrementado
mucho más su erosión creo que está
expresado en este tipo de votaciones y
hacia dónde vamos insisto vamos hacia
hacia un modelo girado hacia la
izquierda pero con diferentes
perspectivas no un modelo mucho más de
izquierda conservadora el del señor
araus y un modelo más progresista en
términos de valores de aceptar a las
diferencias del señor y aqu pérez era
una disputa muy cerrada insisto porque
tengo la impresión que muchos de los
empresarios que votaron por el señor
lazo en esta ocasión difícilmente
podrían girar hacia la perspectiva de ya
coopers así el profesor le pregunta
entonces con eso que nos está diciendo
qué retos le esperan al nuevo presidente
en ecuador
el reto fundamental es la
reestructuración económica del estado y
ahí es una incógnita saber todavía si ya
q pérez va a mantener los acuerdos con
el fondo monetario internacional- la
cercanía con los eeuu o si va a girar a
una economía más deterioro digámoslo así
eso no se ha conocido ya qu pérez ha
sido muy cauto en eso pero en todo caso
yo creo que cualquiera de los dos que
gane la necesidad del país de seguir en
este proceso de ajuste estructural que
implica una remoción del modelo
económico de los 10 años del ex
presidente correa ahora usted lo
menciona muy bien al ex presidente
correa que está muy arraigada la figura
de él en ecuador que margen de maniobra
tendría la figura del ex presidente que
sigue siendo muy fuerte en ese país a
pesar de encontrarse en el exilio en
bélgica muy fuerte el expresidente ha
dirigido la que la vida política del
país por el twitter y por el facebook
fundamentalmente y creo que en esta
segunda vuelta no va a dejar de serlo es
el eje de la campaña del señor
araus y ha sido el eje de la campaña de
los otros candidatos también porque en
general la campaña de los otros
candidatos ha sido en contra de correr
entonces yo creo que va a seguir siendo
un punto nodal de la de la política del
país inclusive si su candidato el señor
araus pierde en la segunda vuelta
electoral así el profesor gracias por su
completo análisis y por estar aquí con
nosotros con france24 estábamos
conversando con el profesor santiago
basabé politólogo y docente asociado de
ciencias políticas de la facultad
latinoamericana de ciencias sociales de
flacso en el ecuador hablando sobre
estas elecciones y la segunda vuelta que
tendrá lugar el 11 de abril hasta aquí
este de cinco minutos con continué con
nosotros
[Música]